Hello. This is Six Minute
English from BBC
Learning English. I'm Neil.
And I'm Beth.
Maybe the only good thing
about covid
lockdowns was
the return of wildlife
to our towns and cities. Birds, foxes
and deer were seen in the streets
close to people's homes.
Of course, rubbing shoulders with animals,
spending time with them,
is amazing, but imagine a hungry African
elephant stumbling
into your garden
and eating your prize vegetables.
How would you stop it?
It sounds unlikely,
but that's exactly the problem
faced by farmers in Africa.
Yes, as human populations increase,
while natural habitats decline,
people and animals are
increasingly being forced to compete
for space. Wild animals
can endanger humans
when they break into their farms
for food or water
and people might be forced to attack
or even kill these animals
to defend their homes.
This situation, known as 'human-wildlife
conflict' is becoming more frequent,
but in this programme, we'll be hearing
about ingenious farmers in Kenya
who are keeping their food safe from
hungry wild animals and as usual,
we will be learning
some useful new vocabulary.
But first,
I have a question for you, Beth.
Weighing around six tonnes a fully grown
African elephant needs to eat a lot
every day.
But how much exactly? Is it:
a) 50 kilograms of food per day? b)
100 kilograms of food per day?
or c) 150 kilograms of food per day?
Hmm, I'll guess
an elephant eats 150 kilos of food a day.
OK Beth,
we'll find out if that is the right
answer at the end of the programme.
Victor Ndombi is food security officer
for the wildlife charity
'Save the Elephants'.
Victor works at Tsavo National Park
in Kenya, where he's often faced
with wild elephants breaking
into farms for food and water.
Here's Victor explaining more
to Michael Kaloki, reporter for BBC
World Service Programme
'People Fixing the World'.
The conflict usually varies.
What we experience here
is during the crop season,
that is the rainy season,
that's where we usually have
the crop raids. The elephants usually
come here - lots of them
and they crop raid on the crops.
Can I ask you, Victor,
where do these elephants come from?
So, they come from those private ranches,
national parks and they come
to this community. They are looking
for where there is green pasture,
so they come to this community
where we have these nutritious foods.
You know elephants
love maize, beans
and that is the crop that farmers
actually farm, so they come
and eat those crops here,
and also looking for water.
Victor sounds very calm about this,
it's just a way of life
for the people out here.
But elephants do spell big trouble
for farmers. A fully grown
male elephant can weigh the same
as six cars on top of each other.
It's easy to see how they can destroy
crops and livelihoods.
Victor works in a national park,
a large area of land
which is protected by the government
because of its natural beauty, plants
or animals.
He explains that the elephants raid
crops like maize and beans from farmers
in the park. 'To raid' means to suddenly
attack a place and steal from it.
These crop raids
have become more frequent
because elephants are desperate
to find water, and because
the park lacks money to fix broken
fences, which keep wild animals out.
Victor says
the raids have become a way of life
an activity that has become
a regular thing in people's lives
rather than something that happens
only occasionally.
That's no problem
if it's a fox in your rubbish bin,
but African elephants are as big
as six cars on top of each other.
And this spells trouble
for the farmers.
If something spells trouble,
It suggests that
there may be problems in the future.
Fortunately,
there's an unusual solution that has got
people buzzing: bees.
Ancient Kenyan folklore says
that elephants are scared of bees.
That's right - elephants,
the world's biggest
land mammal are scared of an insect
the size of your thumbnail!
Victor's team install beehive
fences to protect farmers' crops.
Real bees work best,
but even a recording
of bees angrily buzzing is enough to
keep the elephants away. Better yet,
the bees also pollinate plants
and even produce honey.
It's good news for the farmer,
but I have to feel a little sorry
for the elephants.
Yes, especially because they need
to eat so much.
I think it's time to reveal
the answer to my question, Beth.
You asked me how much food
an elephant eats per day
and I guessed it was
150 kilogrammes.
That
was the correct answer!
Well done! A fully-grown
African elephant
needs 150 kilograms
of food per day.
OK, let's recap the rest
of the vocabulary
we have learned in this programme
about 'human-wildlife conflict'
- a phrase describing harmful encounters
between humans and wild animals.
If you 'rub shoulders'
with someone, you meet them
and spend time together.
'To raid' means
'to suddenly attack' a place
and steal something.
A 'national park' is a large area
of a country
which is protected by the government
because of its natural beauty, plants
or animals.
If you describe an activity
as 'a way of life',
you mean that it has become a common
or regular event for someone rather
than something that happens
only occasionally.
And finally,
when something 'spells trouble',
it suggests that there may be
problems coming in the future.
Once again, our six minutes are up.
Goodbye for now!
Bye!